[Music]
where did this go
from here if that's what we're realizing
this is this big revelation then where
does it go
after gamestop amc dodge coin dogecoin
whatever then where does it go
there's a huge problem with the thesis
you just laid out because you're right
that's what
the connection people are making is that
but it's a false connection and i'll
tell you why
i started off when i first saw bitcoin i
thought it was
i thought the technology was great it
was awesome when i saw it run up to 17
a 20 000 i was like get out it's going
to crash and i was almost
right on to the day when i thought it
was going to crash
i thought once it crashed it would
disappear and
and then never come back but it didn't i
was wrong about that so i was right
for the timing but i thought it would
just vanish and it didn't why because
enough people believed in it
now the difference between bitcoin
and gamestop is so huge
that they that and this is the mistake
people are making if they if you're
trying to think that one relates to the
other
it doesn't there is a finite amount of
bitcoin
that is out there and that can be
created and there are very complex
understandable models of how you create
them and it creates scarcity
there is literally no amount of game
stop
that could not theoretically be issued
is an endless supply
of shares that can be printed created
so it is not a finite situation what
bitcoin was able to do it you truly have
hit on one
thing it was simply supply and demand
if we think it's valuable it's valuable
however in gamestop there's another
reality involved here
that if the stock stays high for too
long
the company will start selling shares
into the market to raise
it won't stay up you can keep creating
more shares it's not
bitcoin so that's why analysts are out
there that have f that have
do training and research and
fundamentals because they look at their
certain rules of the game because it's
all about supply and demand if you have
companies that just could create and
print more shares
well guess what you're back to 1929 when
you know they when they
or even earlier when they screwed over
cornelius vanderbilt and they just
dumping shares and they created
you've probably seen this at how how the
amendment in america this story how they
screwed over cornelius was available
it's printed shares of some railroad he
had
and they cost the guy like a half a
billion dollars back when
half a billion dollars meant something
but the point is you could just keep
creating shares build us stop be very
very careful right when it comes
to applying that same philosophy of it's
just supply and demand one has an
endless supply
yes one is a finite supply yes and and
i'm sure somebody out there is like well
yeah there's all new different types of
coins that pop up and those coins can be
competitive with bitcoin and maybe they
can drive the
cost of coin down because there is more
supply right
you could make an argument for all this
all i'm trying to say is that i think
people are starting to
wrap their heads around this idea that
like a sneaker is popular because we
decide it is
or my girl likes a purse that purse
isn't worth anything it's worth 30
but because dior says it's worth 5 000
then that's the price but
we dictate that not christian dior
not the at what remember one thing
though
go the things that end up holding their
value
have limited numbers of them this is a
very important point right
there are two things that you need there
are two
things that drive the market i'm an
expert in stock manipulation i am i know
more about that probably anyone on the
planet
i'm not proud of that but it's just true
and there are two sides to a stock
manipulation okay
number one is you must create demand
demand what most people don't focus on
is also the artificial withholding of
supply
why do you diamonds have their value the
reason diamonds have value is because
the of the beers withholds supply
they take supply off the market if they
were to
actually flood the market with supply
diamond prices
would crash okay so it's not
just about what's you can create in
demand it's great also
how much supply is out there and can
that supply be increased
i just invested in baseball trading
cards recently because
but i know it's all based on there's
only three of these cards outstanding
like 10 of these costs all based on
limited supply is this the digital card
they're worthless
is this the digital card thing that they
just put out
i bought real baseball because a friend
of mine dan flash
store that sells cars i just oh no they
just released a digital baseball card
and what they're basically trying to do
is like make a digital version of these
trading cards and people are spending
like hundreds of thousands of dollars on
them it's crazy
but yeah i hear what you're saying and
for whatever reason these coins have
used some sort of like sophisticated
technology
to make sure that there is a limited
applause supply of these coins right
yeah you can't make more bitcoin but you
can right can't you mine for them isn't
there like
yeah but you mined like the you mine for
gold you don't make gold you mine for
gold find the gold and that's it
right so yeah so number one this is a
finite
amount of bitcoin that could ever be
created somewhere between 21 and 23
million i'm not sure exactly what it is
and what happens is the mathematics
behind mining is
as you create more bitcoin and the price
goes higher the mathematical
computations are so much more complex
and
more difficult the amount of energy it
takes and time it takes it's an
incredibly clever
technology and i'm just absolutely
shocked the united states did not my big
fear for bitcoin just so you know
was never that the technology was bad i
always loved blockchain technology
my fear was that it's so cool and so
great how could the government
that is so against money laundering or
any other form of currency they could
control how would they let this go on
that's the part that always i thought
was like they could just stand
clamp down on this and stamp it out
right you know maybe before i know it is
the united states behind bitcoin for i
know and they know where it all is
slowly knows why haven't they
i just said who knows it's not the
united states they have to be right
i mean who really i don't i it defies
logic to me that the u.s that spent
20 years pressuring switzerland and the
cayman islands to give up
every buy that in the county they just
tried so hard to eliminate
all ways to loan the money and they're
suddenly going to say ah
yeah go ahead just you know use bitcoin
or this coin or that coin
and i'm not trying to even say that
bitcoin is just for money laundering
because it's not
bitcoin is used by many many legitimate
people now as a storehouse
of value and the more people that
believe that the more true that becomes
it just there's things no one would deny
that it does the
anonymity lends itself to also
having some group of people use it
for nefarious reasons now that's true of
any situation anything
right you always have good you know good
players bad players but it just seems it
would surprise me the u.s
would not have been more aggressive here
we'll see um you know maybe they're
involved in it and we'll find out that
was the whole big joke the whole time
i mean they have to and i think that
answers your same question earlier about
the first amendment
it's like if you see big tech squashing
right well maybe it's not big tech like
maybe big tech is allowed to do that
because
they're in bed with the united states
government and why would you be able to
grow this big and have that much
influence
yeah if you google if you google how the
wolf of wall street
invented the internet all of this stuff
is because of of my of believe it or not
all this stuff
is causing me with the rule 230 this
ability for platforms to act the way
they do and say that they're not
publishers
that was passed because of a lawsuit i
won against an
early platform i sued the i see one of
the first internet platforms
called prodigy and uh won a huge case
against prodigy back in 1994 or so
and um and this is before they had this
rule this
this fair practices act and basically i
won a
huge judgment in the senate so one of
the senators saw this and they passed
this law through 30
to overturn my judgment so that's the
way you see the internet operating right
now is because of my case
they overturned it because of me i won
against prodigy you can google it
it's on the internet so you created the
internet and you
got rid of quaaludes al gore
the internet is a joke i know but if you
google it i was directly responsible for
the way these platforms operate
it was it was passed to overturn a
victory i had
against a prodigy
you